[Inaudible] there are 1500 active volcanoes on earth.
Just one of those volcanoes could do catastrophic damage,
but at midnight, tonight,
every volcano on the planet is erupted.
You might want to cancel any plans.
How much damage are we talking about here?
What would life be like for the survivors?
And what do you mean? It gets even worse than lava.
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if a bulk panic apocalypse happened tomorrow,
brace yourself.
This may just be the worst weather forecast you're ever going to hear
every volcano on earth,
active or dormant on land or under the sea is
ready to blow the lid off this place.
You can expect to see plumes of Ash, lava, bombs,
and jet spurts on every single continent and in every single
ocean. But I know what you're thinking.
You can take the heat right now. Take a seat there. Sparky.
It's going to get a whole lot worse.
If every volcano on earth erupted at once,
it would set off some high magnitude earthquakes.
This is because so many volcanoes are located near the shifting tectonic plates
of the earth.
And while the lava and earthquakes would certainly do some major damage,
one of the biggest blows we're going to face is the nasty gases that
you out of volcanoes clouds of gas smoke,
and Ash can travel in almost liquid like motions to anywhere in
the world. They could smother the earth in a matter of minutes,
but let's say for a second, you managed to survive the initial explosions.
Well, I've got two very upsetting words for you.
Volcanic Ash,
the volcanic Ash would black out the skies blocking any sunlight in the
process.
This would cause the temperature on earth to plumb it without the
sun.
The Earth's surface temperature would plunge to zero degrees after the first
week, and then to minus 66 degrees.
By the end of the first year and the bright side,
it's not an Inferno of death anymore to make matters worse.
No sunlight means no plants,
which means no food for animals.
Most animal species would go extinct.
As the loss of plants would set off a mass extinction due to its impact
on the food chain hen don't hold your breath for the stragglers.
You can expect acid rain to take care of them.
This is because of those volcanic gases. We mentioned earlier,
hydrochloric acid, hydrogen fluoride, hydrogen sulfide,
and sulfur dioxide would condense in the atmosphere and they would fall to the
earth as rain.
This would then contaminate any fresh water supply we had left,
but what if we had some fighters still kicking?
What would life be like for those living in the aftermath? Well,
the economy isn't going to do you any favors,
the volcanic destruction would cause a complete economic collapse.
Every business and bank would shut down.
You lose access to credit and become instantly unemployed.
Unless you count being a wasteland survivor as your new job.
This is Peter Day, one 24,
coming to you live from inside my underground bunker. You know,
since the apocalypse people lost everything, not me.
I had a plan, you know,
even before the economy literally burnt to the ground,
I invested in gold owning gold can act as a hedge against
inflation deflation. And in this case, the apocalypse,
it's literally the gold standard for value and can provide financial well
coverage. In these uncertain times,
you should head on over to the sponsor of this video.
J M bullion.com J M bullion is a discreet,
easy to use physical precious metals retailer with over 4 billion in
revenue.
And over 2 million orders shipped JM bullion is one of the largest,
most respected online retailers of physical gold and silver products in the
world. Since using JM bullion.com.
Life down here has been golden cause it's gold.
There's not a lot of people down here to talk to.
It would be full blown post Apocalyptica out there searching
the Ash covered world for aquifers containing fresh water,
venturing out into the wasteland for supplies and living in heated
underground bunkers. Now,
while it is very possible that volcanoes could set each other off by
being in close proximity,
the chances of every volcano on earth exploding at once is
highly unlikely,
but it does make us think about how quickly things can go South.
What if we could prepare for something like this?
What if we built the world's deepest bunker? Well,
that's a story for another. What if
[inaudible].